americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 32
sad as it is today 32 americans
abandoned by joe biden trapped behind
enemy lines of the taliban taliban now
holding up to 500 of our fellow citizens
hostage along with thousands of other
u.s visa and green card holders they are
all in serious danger all hostages of
the taliban terrorists back here at home
the biden administration is facing
another crisis accusations of treason
they are now swirling around the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
mark milley now these are very serious
serious allegations as always on this
program we do believe in the presumption
of innocence it has served us well over
these many years we believe in due
process nope we don't follow the mob we
won't rush to judgment
but the revelations in an upcoming book
from bob woodward and robert costa are
extremely damning if they are true
downright dangerous to this great
republic and tonight woodward and costa
they have now put out a statement they
are fully standing behind their story in
total as the washington post reports
chairman milley made two secret phone
calls to a chinese official during
trump's final months in office to assure
communist china that the united states
was not planning an attack here's the
key line quote in the book in the books
account milly went so far as to pledge
that he would on his own alert his
counterpart
in the event of a u.s attack in other
words give them a heads up
millie allegedly telling his chinese
counterpart quote general lee you and i
have known each other now for five years
if we're going to attack i'm going to
call you ahead of time it's not going to
be a surprise let me read that again
if we're going to attack i'm going to
call you ahead of time
either that line is false and woodward
and costa's reporting is nothing but a
total bs lie or that would mean the only
option i see is that millie would be a
traitor
i don't see any middle ground here it's
one way or the other there's you know
there's more
in this whole thing and it's equally
damning the upcoming book also alleging
that general milley sought to undermine
president trump's nuclear powers and
shortly after receiving a phone call a
very
well hyperventilating nancy pelosi
demanding that the nuclear football be
taken away from president trump general
milley according to this book summoned
his senior officers and informed them
that he must be involved in any decision
to launch nuclear weapons quote looking
each in the eye milly asked the officers
to affirm that they had understood
the author's right in what is considered
an oath
the question is now simple was general
milly colluding with nancy pelosi third
in line to be president second in line
after
vice president pence
was he colluding with pelosi to assert
the constitutional power
and authority of the president of the
united states or as he now states was he
just performing routine procedural
training regarding a nuclear strike if
millie was colluding with pelosi to
undermine
the constitutional authority of the
commander-in-chief the president
and take away the president's ability to
do his job as commander-in-chief one of
those jobs would be perhaps to launch a
nuclear weapon he would then be guilty
of the very definition of insurrection
that's the democrats favorite word and
again the president is the
commander-in-chief our constitution is
clear it authorizes the president and
the president alone with that power and
authority over our military there is no
constitutional authority granted to the
chairman of the joint chiefs general
milley and certainly not the speaker of
the house nancy pelosi not anyone else
but the president our republic is
designed to prevent a military and
political coup that's why civilian
leadership the duly elected president of
the united states is the
commander-in-chief in charge of the
military so what we're describing here
is a constitutional crisis of the
highest order quote an act or instance
of revolting against civil authority or
an established government
now an investigation a commission it
must be formed immediately we don't have
time to wait here there are three
critical steps that must be taken as
part of any probe one we need to talk to
all the people that were in that room
that made that quote oath to general
milly when he made those comments and
when he called his chinese counterpart
two
we need to see the transcripts of the
calls and that's the calls with millie
and china's counterpart and the calls
with nancy pelosi we need to know
everything that pelosi and millie said
and everything that they did were millie
and pelosi colluding were they
essentially staging a military political
coup because they thought they knew
better than donald trump anointing
themselves commander commander-in-chief
an obvious by the way and as obvious as
joe biden's cognitive decline is imagine
what would happen
if this were done to him imagine the
outrage and three congress by the way
they need to subpoena all of the
documents every single last one of them
and every single transcript now
according to woodward and costa there
are meeting notes there are emails there
are letters there are other documents
and maybe the most important of all
there are transcripts surrounding
millie's call with pelosi and likely his
counterpart in china plus the u.s
monitors every single official phone
call to china there is definitely a
record out there woodward and costa say
they have all this information but while
the serious matter is being investigated
due to the severity of the allegation
and our belief in due process and the
presumption of innocence
this is so serious the only way i see to
handle this is to immediately appoint a
commission it must be nonpartisan
general milley in the meantime must be
put on administrative leave and that of
course pending this full investigation
he is the highest ranking military
official in the u.s and now one of two
things is true
millie is a dangerous trader
who could put our country in serious
danger or woodward and costa are liars
and if woodward and costa and the
washington post are lying and slandering
general milly because that would be
slander he will own the washington post
and potentially probably a good chunk of
if not all of amazon considering jeff
bezos owns both after a massive
defamation suit i don't know the answer
tonight i know it's serious enough that
it needs immediate attention immediate
appointment of a commission and we need
immediate answers and the american
people have a right to see all of those
transcripts sooner than later had no
problem releasing transcripts of donald
trump's calls with foreign leaders so
that should not be a problem right now
tonight woodward and acosta they are
refuting allegations that their
reporting is greatly exaggerating which
brings us to an important ethical
question raised by the great one mark
levin last night right here on this show
if woodward and costa if they're so
competent in their reporting and a known
traitor is at the helm of our military
then how could they possibly justify
holding back such critical information
of such great national importance for
months
the washington post they okay with their
reporters saving vital national security
information of great importance to the
entire country to the american people
hold it off as long as possible after
you finish your manuscript and they got
to produce the book after the editing
that process usually takes months i've
written four books and then sell that
information in the form of a book
instead of alerting the american people
right up front take a look
woodward and costa are reporters for the
washington post
takes two and a half to three months to
print a book
that means woodward and costa and the
washington post if this is true sat on
this story for months and months
why would two reporters sit on a story
like this for months and months
and allow this man who i believe if this
is true is utterly unhinged to serve as
the head of the joint chiefs of staff
you have two so-called journalists who
sat on this
now at the very least woodward and costa
in the washington post they have a duty
to provide proof they should release
their transcripts to the public they
should prove it right now because it's
such importance to the american people
and our national security because of now
dozens of top officials are calling on
milli to resign that includes president
trump's acting secretary of defense
christopher miller who says he did not
authorize millie's calls to china that's
a big deal in and of itself and then you
have general keith kellogg also calling
on milly to step down along with more
than a dozen top lawmakers even
alexander vinman remember the democratic
party star witness in the ukraine
impeachment hoax he's calling on milly
to resign tonight as always we will
grant the same presumption of innocence
to milly that we would for anyone else
it has served this program well over the
many years we have done it 25 years here
at fox 33 years on radio but the left in
the media mob they love to throw around
the word insurrection on the other
channels they talk about it almost every
night but now with one of our highest
officials accused of plotting his very
own insurrection perhaps in conjunction
with some
on some level with the speaker of the
house to us usurp and null and void the
crystal clear constitutional
role that the president has and the role
defined in that constitution for the
president as commander-in-chief many on
the left they're silent tonight
including joe biden today had nothing
but praise for general milley hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else